thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to adore
hello hello everybody thank you so much
for joining us here on daily with Doc
and you if you are on YouTube or rumble
or Facebook welcome welcome welcome
you are also invited to join us here
live in the zoom meeting if you would
like to do so you can go to daily with
Doc zoom.com
and we have our co-hosts that are
watching the room to make sure that
those that really want to be here for
great intention are here and those who
don't are not so I love the fact that we
can create a safe place here for the
whole Community to be able to focus on
information that is empowering
information that allows you to be able
to take your health
more into your own hands and actually
write that Journey we always talk about
you know writing a story
well what story would you write for
yourself is it required record please
oh thank you we're gonna do extra
records so I've got one record going
we're going to go ahead and start this
other record as well recording in
progress
all right thank you so much Ruth Ellen
see it takes a community to do things
right so I am so thankful for my
community and the people that I have
been able to surround myself with
because of this great opportunity to
share empowering information and this is
information that has decades and Decades
of not just research but application as
well application and taking that
research and then applying it to life
and
you know
it's funny because
there's there's those movements of not
having any animal testing well if an
animal didn't pass away or die or have a
sickness
and then somebody with an incredible
mind be able to look at that that animal
that being that creation and figure out
okay what's missing that's causing this
animal to be in the situation that it is
in or was in before it found its demise
well we have with us each and every
weekday a man who has that mind who is
able to be Blazer focused
on what was going on in the specimen in
the environment and all of the different
factors
that go into Health whether it's poor
health
or making those corrections to create
good health
and I am so honored
oh my name is Becca Dukes so I didn't
say that in the beginning and you were
watching daily with dom
and I am so very honored to bring to you
somebody who has made such a positive
impact in my life and my health before I
even physically met the man I heard him
on the radio
I had tried everything
I didn't look forward to getting old
because I hurt so bad and the medical
community
wasn't helping I was just getting worse
and worse so without further Ado I just
want to introduce to you
who a man who is a naturopathic
physician
and on his path to become a naturopathic
physician he got three post doctorates
and pathology he was a doctor of
veterinary medicine as a Bachelor of
Science and agriculture
and looking at soils and plants so I
think he is the perfect person
to be
delivering a message
of what we can do
and our own lives to create that better
health Journey Dr Joel Wallach welcome
to daily with Doc well thank you so much
Rebecca and thank you team for everybody
being here uh we have lots of people to
help out there a lot of things that need
to be done and today we want to talk
about exercise without supplementation
of suicide okay it's one of my great CDs
exercise without supplementation suicide
and let's just look at some gross things
here grows for advisories
um when people sweat regardless of why
you're sweating if you're working in a
big steel mill Factory with all the you
know the big boilers and broilers and
heaters and everything like that and
melting steel
um
the
um let's see here you're gonna sweat
anywhere from five to seven liters
of sweat
okay
per day
if you're
um let's see here
exercising twice a day
you'll be sweating
9 to 12 liters of
sweat per day
now sweat is not just water your purpose
of sweat is to keep the body cooled into
functioning temperatures and it helps
you keep your body temperature in
functioning areas
a new sweat you're sweating out of soup
to contains vitamins and minerals amino
acids and all kinds of stuff like that
not just water if you don't believe me
just next time you sweat just lick your
wrist or your arm or something like that
most people can't reach down and lick
their bellies and reason it's like your
arm and your in your wrist and you'll
you'll feel or you'll taste all that
salt okay we're talking about
the average person who exercises
um uh every day
um their life exp and don't supplement
people who exercise every day and don't
supplement their average life expectancy
is
56.7 even billionaires billionaires who
exercise daily but don't supplement
because they think well I'm spending you
know 200 bucks twice a week for a meal
in a restaurant so that's bound to have
something in it okay I don't use a
supplement and so they don't settlement
and they're in the billionaires who
don't supplement even if they're
exercising they their life expectancy is
something like 66
0.3
not very good so what's going on here
well when you're sweating again your
sweat is full of salt is full of trace
minerals we're talking about copper and
zinc and selenium and and so forth and
I've double checked that again today
it's not just my imagination
and so sweat is a soup it contains all
the the mineral nutrients there in
suspension in solution uh going around
your body being pumped by the heart and
this is why
people say well why are these young
athletes dying of heart attacks why are
these young athletes getting type 2
diabetes why are these young athletes
getting stroke why are these young
athletes dying of ruptured aneurysms
well that's because these are caused by
nutritional deficiencies which was
caused by exercising without
supplementation
and it's one of those things where I
learned that at a very early age I
learned that when I was nine
and when you look at around the world
who lives the longest it's the people
who get the most minerals okay you look
at the hundreds up in the Himalayan
Mountains and we have the Himalayan salt
okay it's in stock again now that our
Himalayan salt just has sodium chloride
salt but it also has like
um
uh I don't know
30 40 50 minerals okay that most people
don't get all right and it's because uh
these people their life expectancy is
120. our life expectancy in America
all right is in the 70s 73 to 75
depending on whose numbers you look at
we don't do very well we're supposed to
have the best health care system in the
world yet we don't we sort of in the
bottom 40 to 50 of the industrialized
world when it comes to longevity and
health why does Australia's life
expectancy 82.9
in terms of 73-75 whereas New Zealand
82.3 why is Japan 84.7 why is Canada 84.
okay why is Italy at 83
um why is um Spain at 82 and so it's
just all these different countries
okay and cultures do much better than we
do when it comes to Health and Longevity
why is that well it's not a medical care
thing it's a nutritional deficiency
thing and sweating contributes to
nutritional efficiencies because sweat
is not just water and rehydrating by
drinking lots of water even expensive
water okay after you exercise is not
going to add many healthful years to
life okay and so this is one of those
things where this has been a passion of
mine for a long time because I was
involved with my personal issues
and I was very very sick and had all
kinds of
um mental emotional and physical
problems when I was nine years old and
they're going to put me in a institution
they called it but it was really just a
hospital that was really just a it was a
jail essentially because it couldn't go
anywhere once they put me in there I was
in there couldn't go out all my visitors
had to be screened and all this kind of
stuff and this is one of that kind of
thing because they were trying to figure
out why that I was such a mess and I
figured it out when I was nine just by
eating animal Alfalfa pellets that have
been supplemented with vitamins and
minerals and in two and a half days all
my symptoms went away
I cured Myself by just eating those
Alfalfa pellets okay that had been
supplemented with vitamins and minerals
made a huge difference obviously well
um I didn't say anything to anybody I
just went about myself and
um they examined me on my way there and
I didn't need to go to that hospital
and in churches and Schools they're all
pointing to me and Whispering because I
was a totally different person in two
and a half days that's because I was
getting the nutrition so that my nerves
would work properly and my brain would
work properly and so on
so this is not something that's
mysterious this is a repeatable
which I say science this is a science
and so this is why we have the healthy
brain and hard pack it has
215 nutrients in it including the 90
which is the core 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 minutes to Three fatty acids
and then of course we have what we call
the secret sauces for like 600 different
health problems some of the secret
sauces will take care of five or six
different problems you know kind of like
um
um let's see here we have the healthy
Bone and Joint pack which is really our
essentially was our our first healthy
um start pack which had the 90 essential
nutrients in it then Theo Ratliff came
to us with his problem so we added the
glucogel which is a collagen that comes
from beef cartilage and we actually
rebuilt him and he came back okay from
really being a mess and losing his spot
it was the Atlanta Hawks a 30 million
dollar contract we rebuilt him he came
back and he played for 11 more years
made over 100 million dollars just by
taking all these nutrients so we have a
lot of experience with this and so
exercise without supplementation of
suicide
we have the CD it's a part of a three CD
Set uh dead athletes don't lie because a
lot of times these athletes you know
they don't live long enough to have lots
of serious joint and back and muscle
problems they just die suddenly of a
hypertrophy cardiopathy heart attack you
know hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
attack thank you hypertrophic
cardinality heart attack
um uh is one of those things which
causes a sudden death in young athletes
and even you know like seniors who were
exercising without supplementation now
I'm very proud to say uh my book
Hell's Kitchen
actually discovered the reason for that
but Hell's Kitchen is a place
in New York City where everything goes
wrong thank you Becca okay where
everything goes wrong in New York City
and so they called it Hell's Kitchen
because it was a bad place well when
you're not getting all the nutrients you
need your behavior is bad your health is
bad and so
um I I realized that there's a reason
why suddenly now we're getting all these
pups that they didn't have 100 years ago
500 years ago a thousand years ago two
thousand years ago well that's that's
because
um in the old days the fuel was wood and
coal and we put the wood ashes and coal
ashes which are 98 minerals and two or
three percent carbon into the gardens
for fertilizer in the in the vegetables
and fruit and berries and things would
um
suck up the minerals okay out of those
ashes and we'd eat those fruits and
vegetables and get those minerals that
way okay and once we went to electricity
uh-oh there were no more ashes everybody
thought that was a great thing then we
had the hydroelectric dams they damned
at the Rivers no more bottom land no
more revitalization of the soil every
year during the floods because the dams
stopped the flooding no more silt going
into the soil and so even the bottom
lamb which was the most fertile land
everywhere in the world once we put up
the hydroelectric dams to stop the
flooding and be able to make electricity
okay
from hydroelectric well guess what
suddenly now
everything got worse
this is not difficult
okay and we have proven this and proven
this improving this and so this is why
we do what we do to get this information
out there and you'll pay wholesale
prices to become one of our registered
customers you get on the auto ship I
will pay the shipping I personally do
not
get paid by youngevity as an employee of
youngevity okay it's one of those things
I set it up that way I started youngin
okay but I set it up so I you know
people wouldn't say well yeah you're
pumping all those vitamins Minerals Well
because you get paid no okay I have to
make my living
um just like everybody else okay I I
have my books which I sell I do sell
products okay but I have to buy the
product then sell the product okay I'm
not um being paid by Young Jody based on
the amount of product I sell okay it's
one of those things where it's just
crazy okay and so I set it up that way
so nobody can say well yeah you're
pushing all those vitamins Minerals Well
like because you you know that's how you
make your living well just don't forget
the three CD set dead athletes don't lie
exercise those limitations of suicide
what kills billionaire those three CDs
are in a set okay
which we call
okay there's a new Bull in town you can
figure that one out yourself there's a
new Bull in town okay and so this
information on here
can add 25 to 50 Health years your life
it'll certainly eliminate an enormous
amount of unnecessary misery and saving
an enormous amount of savings when it
comes to money
get this three CD set get to book Hell's
Kitchen get on the 90 essential
nutrients better yet the 215 nutrients
and you will be blessed okay that's
that's the God thing okay okay so with
all that said Rebecca
um do you have any questions for me are
we we have lots of questions for you Dr
Wallach and the first one today and let
me let me just say this folks this
program is for educational information
only it is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician and our
products do not treat diagnose or cure
any diseases the FDI requires us to let
you know this
but Dr Wallach has sued the FDA more
than nine times but has nine victories
and those victories have allowed us to
be able to present this information to
you as factual and things that have been
proven to
make a difference Dr Wallach positive
impacts
let me interrupt everything because at
that point uh you don't hear anything
about suddenly death syndrome anymore
SIDS doctors said it was because my
mother's laying on the babies and
suffocating was one of my well not one
but all those lawsuits always allowed us
to we want every one of them it allowed
us to put these nutrients into baby
formulas and it stopped all these sudden
deaths and these babies that the doctors
are blaming on the mothers laying on
them and suffocating okay and so we're
very very proud of that
you know absolutely Dr Wallach and it's
because of that many many many years
later
that you received in 2011 the claw
Schwartz award
that's correct very proud of that very
proud of that
in 2015 I got the Lifetime Achievement
Award from the United Nations boy talk
about that
I'm just a dumb foreign boy from
Missouri
I'm just I'm so proud that we were able
to contribute so much to the benefit of
humanity and it was recognized
okay by large organizations including
the organization of world governments
okay that suddenly now we had answers
for these things that doctors were just
pointing to silly things like mothers
laying on the babies and suffocating
their their babies and um that kind of
stuff
well I just want to speak to all the
moms and dads out there that have kiddos
that are struggling with being able to
behave and focus and have all of these
things going on when you give
that young Soul the nutrients that they
need in order to thrive
they can do great things and Dr Wallach
is just proof of that
so that that gives me hope
and I hope that that gives others hope
as well Dr Wallach
because you've you've figured it out and
now we're sharing what you figured out
with the world
and there's going to be no more excuses
so folks if you're hearing this message
you're hearing this message
for a reason for a purpose
we have the live stream on YouTube we
have it on Rumble we have it on Facebook
go to those outlets and share this
information share this video with
somebody that you know that
may be dealing with something that we
are discussing in today's program we
also have almost three years now Dr
Wallach of recordings
on
criticalhealthnews.com and also Daily
with doc.com sharing your message and
the message of pharmacist Ben Fuchs that
supports your message and giving us
those nuggets that we can use within our
lives
on our own without having to get
permission from anybody else because we
are empowered individuals Dr Wallach
absolutely absolutely and of course we
we came up again with our great rebound
or sports drink with 100 nutrients in it
a hundred nutrients in one drink okay
we're talking 75 minerals and 25
vitamins amino acids and it comes in
sticks it comes in a can it comes it
comes in a can comes in a cast iron
powder and all these things and so
there's no reason people have and
economic access to this stuff we're not
charging them a thousand dollars of
treatment okay we're talking pennies a
day they had 25 to 50 Health figures
your life I mean come on
well it I'm talking about
you know 100 that are spent on
treatments I know people that are going
through IV therapies where they're
getting a boost of B vitamins and
glutathione and and it's that one time
thing Dr Wallach I know we didn't
discuss this prior but when when you do
a one-time
injection into the body
and then compare it to
putting those nutrients into the body
each and every day
for me
you get better results and and I can
only say this because I did it
I did it
and I did not get the results that I
received when I got on the nutrition
it's an everyday thing folks it's not a
One-Shot deal think that you're going to
be all good and dandy because it doesn't
work that way
but you put the body
where it needs to be with the nutrients
that it can absorb and utilize
and you're writing a whole new story for
yourself
now this is well said let me interrupt
here and again if you're going to
exercise remember exercise I've sewing
Tina suicide you can't just take the
supplements once a day
you're exercising heavy or you're
working a steel mill okay we're sweating
from the Heat and the exercise
you better be taking these nutrients
twice a day okay and if you're 300
pounds you better be taking it three
times a day okay because there's a
weight function environment all these
things are impacting
how much of the nutrients you're going
to get use out of how many you're going
to retain how many you're going to sweat
out how many are going to pee out and
all this kind of stuff and so
um it's just like your car you check
your oil every time you go in and fill
up your car with gas okay do you wait
until there's no more oil left in your
car before you put six parts all back in
it no if you're down a half apart you're
gonna you're gonna put that oil in there
okay same way with your transmission
fluid same with your brake fluid you got
to treat yourself as well as you treat
your car
you treat yourself better than your
creature
I don't know pretty well they only take
this they only take a shower once a week
but they give their car their car a bath
every day
oh goodness well Dr Wallach we have
people with their hands up we've got
questions on YouTube and in the chat and
in email so let's go ahead and go to the
first hand that is up and we have
somebody that is joining us from a
Samsung phone
go ahead and unmute yourself if you
would please
oh we've got a lot of feedback so I
don't know if you have this also playing
on another device I was I was I turned
it off yeah thank you so much
yeah
um and my weight is 122. my age is 32 my
high is 5'9
um
was uh was there something else that you
guys were asking for yeah you have a
problem
yeah um so I talked to you on December
8th if you remember yeah it was
happening with insomnia
yeah but it kind of like um it's really
also anxiety and panic attacks now for
specific reasons like
to really summarize it fast like
um in August again show me because of
ADHD stimulus I took so I kicked it off
and I got down under control I even
stopped taking that since October but
then
um since dying workout I try like
hypnosis for ADHD and that basically
like broke my nervous system I'm not
sure why and then after that started
getting panic attacks and still uh and
so me is like really not bad okay but
when you have ADHD this is a biochemical
deficiency problem okay
when you have emotional problems anxiety
uh memory problems all these sorts of
things anger rage these are all
nutritional deficiency problems and at
100 and you say 122 pounds
um and let's see here you need to be
getting rid of all the bad stuff no
fried foods I mean no fried foods and no
air frying pan frying deep frying no
fried foods no sugar of any kind no
honey no molasses no sugar then
absolutely no oils no cooking oils
no
um salad dressings I like to use lemon
wedges and lemon drops on my salads or
maybe even yogurt with shells that
require creamy dressings I use yogurt
and then absolutely no gluten no wheat
no I ran oats that means no wheat no
about Ryan oats in any way shape or form
there are no such things as gluten-free
oats because they will destroy your
intestinal lining so you cannot
efficiently absorb nutrition you can
take all the nutrition you want but if
you're eating gluten you're not going to
get any benefit okay so it seems to me
like you're cheating somewhere and
you're getting gluten you're eating
gluten you're eating wheat bread around
Oats Oatmeal don't do it okay then you
also have to stay away from buckwheat
buckwheat doesn't have gluten in it but
it does have fago Pyrenees fago Pyrenees
which is worse than gluten and
destroying your intestines and then no
carbonator drinks this includes diet
drinks okay and also carbonated water
because carbonation neutralizes your
stomach acid and your stomach acid is is
is made from hydrochloric acid okay you
need to be salting your food with tip
for Taste we have two a great salt
sources one is seasoned salt it's called
it has like I don't know 28 different
minerals in it including the sodium
chloride that's from Australia New
Zealand now we have the Himalayan salt
again which has the sodium chlorides
salt and also about the same I don't
know 28 30 different minerals in there
from the Himalayan mountains
and I use them both okay so my stomach
works good I can digest a steel bar okay
and so you need to eat three eggs twice
a day because your brain is 25
cholesterol and your spinal cord is 25
claw cholesterol no cholesterol lowering
drugs no stand drugs no no no okay and
then I also want you to take an addition
to three eggs twice a day at noon time I
want you to take two servings of our
I-26 okay comes in powder it comes in
capsules and it comes in vanilla flavor
chewables little discs okay I take two
of those chewables at lunchtime okay in
addition my three eggs twice a day and
if you do all that
your problems will go away we deal with
thousands of kids and people of all ages
that have all your problems
but you got to be the one in control
here the doctors just can't give you an
injection to something and make all that
stuff go away it requires nutrition for
your brain to work your spinal cord to
work okay biochemically and mechanically
okay so give us a call every couple of
weeks get on the program and give us a
you know give us a report every couple
of weeks two weeks four weeks six weeks
you should recover very quickly okay
um you should recover very quickly
because this is only just a biochemical
thing not genetic not autoimmune it's
easily prevented easily fixed so get on
it and we're looking forward to hearing
from you
does that mix well with the prescription
that they gave me a problem uh 0.25
million now see he's giving you your
doctor is giving you a prescription that
covers the symptoms doesn't get to the
root cause of the problem
[Music]
okay if you're so dangerous you're going
to kill yourself well then you might
want to take that medication to treat
the symptoms but you still got to get
rid of the problem by getting the
nutrition
and you got to get rid of the bad foods
you can absorb the nutrition so you
don't need to take that medication
no that was foreign I mean there's
nothing like suicide or killing myself
it's just insomnia and anxiety okay well
I've said it now three times the
medication only results symptoms does
not get down to the basic root cause now
you want to be on medication for the
rest of your life just don't change
anything the doctors will be happy to
keep giving you prescriptions and
building your insurance company
okay
all right Rebecca what's next
thank you so much great questions
there's a lot of people Dr while like
that have anxiety and insomnia yeah no
deficiencies and eating the wrong Foods
really do play into that so it's
something to seriously consider
Dr wellick let's go to a question from
email here and James says I have chronic
pain from nerve damage in both legs he
potties all night long a lot at night he
says there's lots of pain uh he was a
stunt man and so he's experienced a lot
of car crashes and Falls he has COPD he
has liver damage
and
he wants to know what you would
recommend for him because he doesn't
want to take all the pain medications or
the medications that they give him and
he also has high blood pressure did he
give us a weight
oh it's 186 pounds
at five foot eleven Okay so
um he's definitely got uh we'll have a
pressure COPD trying to constructive
pulmonary disease
um
he's getting up when he says potty I'm
assuming he's urinating several times a
night he's going to ask he approaches
the skull squeezing uh the spinal cord
okay uh causing the spinal cord to tell
the urinary bladder to urinate that's
why that's happening uh COPD also the
tenth cranial nerve could be squeezed
causing that to happen Okay a high blood
pressure very simple a nutritional
deficiency
let's see here
and then of course he needs the minerals
for all the stuff going on in his knees
and his hips and his legs and so on so
here we go none of the bad foods no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no gluten no wheat bread around no sugar
no carbon or drinks I want them to have
two healthy brain and heart pasture
months two healthy abandoned heart
passion Mountain Festival 215 nutrients
in the which includes the 90 essential
nutrients in each one of those packs a
full dose everything twice a day I want
him also to have two bottles a month to
the MSM so you can take three at
breakfast dinner time
and that's going to give him what he
needs to support promote means repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between invertebrate bone
makes bone self including the skull
so then he needs a collagen peptides
which is collagen uh let's see here you
know we're talking about cartilage
leaving the tendons connective tissue
from fish poultry sheep and beef a scoop
of that with this morning drinks Cooper
that was his evening drink I do want him
to have two servings a day or a rebound
or sports drink you can either have you
know two of these a day one breakfast
one at dinner time the sticks we have
these
okay we have the canister of rebound
there's 36 servings in here you could
have a scoop of that with a morning
drinks whether the evening drink and
then we have the cans if he prefers the
cans uh 12 ounce cans there's 12 cans in
a case but the cans do have carbonation
so you do have to pop the tops on them
at night I put two of them in the
refrigerator at night and so off gas and
at night and they'll be flat in the
morning all the bubbly's gone so I can
have one with breakfast one saved
between noon and two
I don't want to take it too late in the
afternoon she'll be up all night and
then now let's see here
um
we do have also oxy body you can take an
ounce of that a breakfast downstairs two
parts a month and the liver okay will be
taken care of okay bye by the public
branded heart that we could call it the
healthy brain heart liver kidney muscle
and bone pack but that would be too
clumsy so okay so this would cover the
thing and we do want James to call us
every
um every couple of weeks he could call
us earlier if he wants to but don't wait
longer than two weeks because his story
is a common story and we want him to be
able to share his story don't forget our
salt so we make stomach acid okay and
when you're sweating from exercising
you're sweating out your salt which
screws up your your digestion system
okay so don't forget the season salt
from Australia and the Himalayan salt
from Himalayan Mountains okay from punza
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach I'll make sure that James gets
that information
and with her hand up I believe she has a
question that's being asked out on
YouTube possibly
I do have a question from YouTube but I
also have Stephanie who um called
earlier and I promised that if she
couldn't raise her hand I would raise my
hand for her so Stephanie would you like
to unmute so you can ask Dr Wallach your
question
foreign
yes
okay
oh it's such an honor
to be able to talk Dr Wallace thank you
so much how can we help you for all that
you do thank you I am a dialysis patient
and I am uh have been on dialysis for
two years and I have been on the
vitamins and minerals
um for at least six months now my blood
work is perfect and I don't do the full
prescription that they tell me to do I'm
one peritoneal dialysis which they asked
me to do nine hours every night and keep
so much fluid in me during the day but
what I have done is I take weekends off
and I don't keep the fluid in me during
the day and I'm doing fine but I just
don't know I urinate a lot
and they do tests on me monthly blood
work and um urine tests but I don't know
what I'm supposed to be asking as far as
what my kidney function is
stop there for a minute okay you see
here on Dallas says how many times a
week are you getting dialysis three six
uh I'm supposed my prescription is for
nine hours every night
plus keeping fluid inside of me during
the day
however I'm not doing that
I am taking Friday and Saturday night
off and I don't know what you're doing
so you're doing home dialysis as opposed
to going to a clinic and sitting for
three hours to do yes sir okay all right
how much do you weigh
134.
do you have any other issues any help
with pressure diabetes
no diabetes no heart problems
um the only thing I have a little
trouble sleeping and they were giving me
trazodone but I found it was making me
foggy so I quit taking it and now I
don't I sleep a little but not that much
um but I am taking the vitamins and
minerals so I'm hoping that
um it'll get better okay let's stop
there all right you weigh 134 pounds I
want you to again this is for our other
listeners as well I want you to get rid
of all the bad foods you know fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no wheat around oats no sugar no
carbon or drinks
um all that's got to go and then I want
you at 134 pounds you have one healthy
branded heart attack a month a half a
dose of everything at breakfast half a
dose during the dinner time I want you
to take one bottle a month of our MSM so
you can take three breakfast free at
dinner time they will support and
promote major pair of cart leisurely
events tendons connective tissue discs
between the vertebrae bone weight bone
itself
then I also want you to have the
collagen peptides take a scoop of that
at morning drinks with an evening drink
I also want you to have a rebound or
sports drink and a your body weight you
could take Highway 142 and I'd take the
two doses a day
of the rebound but we have the sticks
you know which I showed you this is you
know has 100 nutrients maybe you can
take one of you know with the breakfast
one at noon time
um and then we do have the canister of
the powder we do have the cans we're
going to use the cans you got to pop
them and let the gas go out at night in
the refrigerator so they're flat in the
morning but no bubbly okay and then for
the sleep we do have sleepies you can go
ahead and take a dose of sleepies 15
minutes for bedtime
um
and we do have uh I think we still have
our decaffeinated coffee back in in
stock and check that out a decounty okay
and you do want to stay away from
caffeine you want to stay away from
caffeine okay
um I usually drink two cups in the
morning okay yeah yeah okay yeah we have
a great coffee and of course our coffee
we actually use our blooming minerals
are our fertilizer with all these
different nutrients and 75 minerals for
our coffee okay I'm gonna say my if
you're not using our coffee you might
try our coffee because it does have the
um minerals in it okay yes sir okay and
then call this area a couple of weeks
let us know what's going on because your
story is not unusual and so people are
going to want to hear your story okay
is there anything okay one other thing
for the dialysis I'm looking at my small
print here because the dialysis I do
want you to take
three of our ultimate daily plastic
tablets twice a day it'll be two bottles
a month ultimate daily classic tablets
take three breakfast free dinner time
and they're designed to support and
promote healthy blood pressure healthy
blood flows or blocked arteries and also
help support healthy function of the
kidney when it comes to filtering urine
and all that kind of stuff and so the
whole idea here is to wean you off a
dialysis by actual laboratory tests you
know you go to the doctor say you know
do our program for say
um 60 days two months and then you go
and say Hey I want to check and see do I
really still need to be doing dialysis
okay they're not going to tell me no
though go to it go to the university go
to a medical school at the University
and ask them if you really need to keep
doing dialysis let somebody else do it
not them
okay
okay I need to order all this stuff so
I'll need to
call the number I guess yep that's your
suggestion
you know those they'll you can see here
Rebecca do you
Ruth Ellen
so Stephanie what you'll do is you'll
get back with a person that's been
helping you with your previous order
I've already started on the products so
and Dr Wallach one thing I picked up on
is she's urinating a lot her LAB Works
she said are perfect
yet they still have her on dialysis five
days a week which I know the Perryton
um I can never say it right
Carrie Tennille thank you Stephanie
um
all day all the time Are there specific
things Dr Wallach that you can recall
that are tests that tell whether or not
the kidneys are working now oh yeah I
mean one clue is she's urinating
and see well she could have how she
approaches the skull squeezing that
spinal cord and the spinal cord is
telling the urinary bladder to urinate
I do have osteoporosis
okay if you have osteoporosis and any
bone in your body you got in your skull
as well okay a squeezing the spinal cord
and that's what's causing you to urinate
so much
oh
so for our audience Dr Wallach what are
signs to look for that tell you that
your kidneys are not functioning
well you're not urinating that's one
okay okay
another one
um
you want to
um you can actually go to a pharmacy
without a prescription get you know
urine test strips and check your own
urine and see if there's sugar in there
if there's blood in there or anything
like that but it wouldn't you know hurt
I'm sure these doctors have all just
asked you know ask for a copy of the
results of all your last tests with them
because you want to see you know how
your kidneys are doing right if you want
to see if you can cut your dialysis from
six or from three days a week to to one
day a week or from six days a week to
three days a week you want you want to
cut your dialysis okay and if they say
oh no you got to have okay well then
just excuse yourself and then you go see
another doctor I go to the university
the closest University that they have
less
um which I say
hanky-panky going on
so there are more there well they're
more education driven instead of dollar
driven even though education is being
paid for and supplied by the dollar
it's a
spider web Dr Wallach it really is well
Annette out on YouTube she says what
about correcting gout and she is a horse
breeder of 40 years so she's familiar
with the whole the way animals
function and the importance of being
able to figure out what they need
without them telling you do we have do
we know how much she weighs did she give
you any of that information Stu plus gal
in general Dr Wallach it's an arthritis
okay let's go buy
um 100 pounds of body weight okay
okay so yes please okay gout none of the
bad stuff no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat and
oats no buckwheat no sugar no carbon or
drinks of any kind and then I want her
to have
let's see here per 100 pounds of body
weight I wanted to have uh let's start
out with something really simple with a
Healthy Start pack okay because the
um
that'll be very simple uh take a half a
dose
twice a day per 100 pounds of body
weight okay and
um then she can take our CM cream
topically on any joint that's painful
okay the same cream apply that to the
Joint it's painful or joints that are
painful and that will give you a couple
hours of relief of the discomfort
and let's see here
um then say I would say like once a
month I wouldn't hurt to uh you know get
a blood test and see what's going on
with the gout okay and then give us a
call back but it started what would you
be looking for in that blood test Dr
Wallach when it comes to gout
okay well there's all these various
um let's see here
um these would it be a uric acid levels
uric acid levels yeah well that's a good
place to start yep
see
let's see acid proteins okay in certain
foods okay and so she obviously she's
been told if she has gout she's been
told what foods to avoid and all that
kind of stuff just go to Siri and serial
type for nothing
no well I I know from past and listening
to you Dr Wallach that there's some
people in experience also that uric acid
uric acid uric acid
well no I was going some people with you
mentioned foods and it can be triggered
by Foods one of them being shellfish and
there's also actually a healthy body
start pack that is shellfish free for
those who have that sensitivity well
there you go
so I love having Solutions Dr Wallach
that we don't leave anybody out in order
to get the nutrition okay
all right well let's go to the next hand
up we have only a few minutes so uh
Carmen
let's go ahead that sounds awful
familiar
her eye is
um
trying to turn her phone
um your eye is um messed up and she woke
up and she couldn't see out of one of
her eyes and she went to the eye doctor
and he told her that it was
um
uh
uh oh I forgot let me see conjunctivitis
no no no no no
Jocelyn Jocelyn what did the doctor tell
you that I have broken blood vessels
inside my eyes not on the outside but
the way that they're breaking is
blinding me and they said that it would
only come from health problems
mumbled noise in the background
house
she has blood broken blood vessels in
her eyes like not outside but inside
inside her eye itself not on the outside
this could be caused this can be we only
got minutes here because this can be
caused by honestly approaches to the
skull squeezing the optic nerve and the
optic artery in the optic vein okay
causing that problem could be highly
pressure could be a deficiency of C of
certain nutrients and some of these
blood vessels in the eye because a
little increase in pressure or rupturing
all kinds of possibilities there so she
needs to get rid of all the bad foods uh
per 100 pounds of body weight she needs
one healthy brain and heart packed per
month if she only weighs 100 pounds to
be uh half a dose to twice a day she
weighs 150 pounds would be two full
doses a day that held the brain and
heart attack she needs the occup I want
to take three octave capsules
um twice a day that's two bottles a
month I want her also to have the vision
FX I also wanted her to have
um the ultimate daily classic ultimate
daily classic I wanted to take the three
of those twice a day that's going to
help her maintain proper blood pressure
and healthy blood flow healthy blood
flow through
um you know all various blood vessels uh
you know give us a call every couple of
weeks give us a call anytime you go back
to the doctor and get some kind of
feedback and we'll you know do what we
can to help you
um support means repair of your eyes and
blood vessels everywhere not just your
eyes
if it's if it's just in the eyes that
means that the skull is squeezing those
arteries and veins if you have that in
your eye but it's everywhere including
your heart and your kidneys and and so
forth okay
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and do you have time for one
more we have time for one more quick one
all right Paul go ahead and unmute
yourself you are on live with Dr Wallach
oh hi again
um uh Dr Wallach I just wanted to get a
quick update going on with a couple of
my um of my co-workers uh Johnny and
Cheyenne we only have moments I know
it's I know you have to Johnny uh she's
been he's been really eating um a lot of
um
well he has like some uh I told him not
to eat any gluten he's been starting to
eat more on cauliflower pizza and rice
pizza but he's been having some stomach
ache issues
okay well he needs the 90s and nutrients
he needs to stay away from the bad foods
if he's having stomach issues he needs
to get our ultimate enzymes take uh you
know two or three of the ultimate
depending on his body weight a couple of
those ultimate enzymes say five or ten
minutes for each meal they help him
digest food don't forget the salt or
season salt from Australian or Himalayan
salt from the Himalayan Mountains that's
going to help him with digestion
okay which will get rid of the stomach
pain and gas and all that kind of stuff
okay we've got time for one more clicky
here all right another quickie Cheyenne
she's uh been taking most of your
product she's okay uh but you know she's
been feeling a lot of lightheadedness
after work
okay line is after work this could be
hypoglycemia low blood sugar more than
likely okay then she needs to be taking
again all the 90 essential nutrients the
healthy brain and heart pack seems to be
taking the um let's see here I'd have
her take the sweeties you could take
three of those twice a day if she weighs
150 pounds if she only weighs 100 pounds
you could take uh to the sweeties twice
a day and then I want her to make sure
that she does have
some protein at breakfast lunch and
dinner she can't just eat cookies and
crackers and things are made out of
carbohydrates because that's going to
contribute to all this okay she can't
skip meals she's got to
um she can have mixed nuts no peanuts
but she can have you know walnuts and
um uh cashews and that kind of stuff
because the nuts they have a lot of
healthy fats in them which will help her
extend her uh healthy calories we also
have a chocolate we have a wonderful
chocolate which is very healthy triple
chocolate is called she could have you
know in the middle of the afternoon like
one or two o'clock in the afternoon have
a couple of our little squares of triple
chocolate she could have a couple more
just before end of the day and that way
it'll keep her blood sugar up there
where she's not going to have low blood
sugar okay all righty uh thank you so
much Doc and uh but hopefully I'll talk
to you again real soon okay thank you
thank you all right thank you Paul well
Dr Wallach we are coming to the end of
the program I just want to thank you
again so much for taking the time out of
your busy busy schedule and joining us
Monday through Friday
from 12 to 12 50 ish
here on daily with Doc so if you're
joining us and you had your hand up and
your head or had a hand a question in
the chat please go to daily
withdoc.com and use that contact us and
send us a message with your question and
we will have one of our certified
holistic health coaches get back with
you with an answer that would be coming
from Dr Wallach this is using protocols
that he has used in the past and
sharing them with you if it's something
that's unique that we feel that there's
more to it where it requires getting
with Dr Wallach we will definitely
arrange that as well because we want to
make sure that you're getting the
information that you deserve as an
individual especially when you are
reaching out and seeking options
if I could just get my co-hosts up here
with me my name is Becca dukes and I
could not do this program without a team
without the support of other individuals
and bringing their talents to the table
where we all work together to provide a
program like this to you
if you were shared this program or
somebody shared this program with you
make sure that you get back with them
they cared enough to take the time to
share this program to help you get
information that can be empowering
something that you can do on your own
and take control of your health and
create a better health Journey today on
behalf of daily with Doc I just want to
thank my co-host Phyllis Anderson Sherry
Browning Marilyn pazara spear Farhan
Nasir and Ruth Ellen Sanchez folks
we have hearts for people and I know
that we're not alone if you have a heart
for people as well and you want more
information about how you too can use
that heart to help Empower others to
create
a healthier communities
then again get back with the person that
share this program with you or you can
get more information by going to
coachwithbecca.com and we'll match you
up with somebody in your local area
until next time
oh also we have a call team
855-949-3377 so if you'd like to call
and speak with a certified holistic
health coach please use that number and
this is for people that have never
spoken to anybody about Dr Wallach about
youngevity
855-949-3377
bye for now
recording
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]